I've been all over his Lake for 62 years
never seen nothing like this just
happened in my lifetime
well it's certainly not our friend oh
they say it doubles in size every four
to five days and it has real long
tentacles into the water
it is literally a monster that is
overtaking one of the most beautiful
places I've ever been the weevils are
the best bet because its nature fighting
nature if it wasn't for the wheel it
would be a bad trouble this is giant
salvinia
scientists call it the world's worst
weed on the surface it looks friendly
enough it's bright green fuzzy and it
has small oval leaves but make no
mistake it is a litte killer giant
salvinia is an invasive species from
Brazil that first appeared in Texas in
1998 under ideal conditions that can
cover 40 square miles in three months
boats can't drive through it native
plants can't grow underneath it and fish
and other wildlife struggles to survive
for 20 years we tried to get rid of it
somebody even tried to kill it with a
blowtorch once today we use an
integrated approach to manage salvinia
including a very small and unique insect
from Brazil
[Music]
my 2013 a group of us became convinced
that weevils help promised to come back
giant salvinia so we organized the
grassroots effort to build a weeble
greenhouse here in uncertain Texas the
main goal of the greenhouse is to raise
a large army of weevils with a diet of
fresh salvinia and once their numbers
expand to a certain level then we take
them out onto the look I've never raised
bugs before and I'm not an entomologist
everyone here is volunteer and the
reason we're doing this is because we
care about the lake today
we have raised three hundred and fifty
thousand weevils this is not an easy
fight but it's worth trying to do this
they'll continue to do it I'll continue
to do it and most people down here will
continue to do what they can to save
this like
[Music]
we've had a few small areas of success I
grew up here in panel and pond and three
years ago it was covered in salvinia but
since the release of the weevils we've
seen slow but dramatic change Caddo Lake
is a unique treasure I've fallen in it
up swam in it I fished and hunted in it
this lake has been part of my soul for
almost 50 years fighting the salvinia is
not an easy task it's not glamorous or
flashy but the men and women who fight
it have no intention of losing and at
the end of the day we're all in it for
the long run
[Music]